[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock here in the uk very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news today we'll bring you the latest
from afghanistan and indeed around the
world following yesterday's suicide bomb
attacks at kabul airport in which at
least 80 people have died an emotional
president biden spoke at the white house
last night as the number of u.s soldiers
killed rose to 13. i'm going to be
speaking to the defense secretary ben
wallace in just a few moments time
also this morning for you we'll hear
from the former afghan interpreters for
the british army who say they're being
denied a seat on rescue flights to the
uk more on that and the last rescue
flight landed in germany early this
morning officials in berlin say
just too dangerous for them to carry on
it's friday the 26th of august
the rescue goes on for the brits and
americans continuing flights from kabul
despite yesterday's suicide bombing
these are live images from kabul airport
we will respond with force and angry
president biden says the united states
will take action against those
responsible for the attacks
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
here in the united states the
politicians are reeling after one of the
deadliest days in the afghan campaign
meanwhile thousands are still waiting to
leave afghanistan evacuation flights
will still continue here to doha but
getting out safely is now much more
complicated
changing times american military
officials confirmed they are now
cooperating with the taliban against
islamic state
and it's looking fine and settled for
today and it looks fine as well for the
bank holiday weekend but there will be a
fair amount of cloud around as well i'll
have the details for you later
[Music]
good morning the taliban says the death
toll from yesterday's suicide bomb
attack has risen to at least 80.
13 american soldiers were also killed
reports from kabul say 28 taliban were
among the dead despite the attack rescue
flights are continuing this morning
we've seen live pictures from kabul
airport where people have been snaking
onto the airplane yesterday the target
was a massive western evacuation effort
at the airport the attackers struck
outside the perimeter fence one bomb hit
crowds of afghans near the barren hotel
an assembly point for anyone trying to
access rescue flights gunfire followed
possibly from troops responding to the
blast there was also an explosion at
abbey gate that killed u.s soldiers a
suicide bomber is suspected of targeting
the entry point where body searches were
taking place their attack also hit
afghans who've been using a sewage canal
while queueing for rescue flights
let's get more reaction to events in
afghanistan from around the world sally
lockwood is in doha forest greg milam is
in los angeles let's go to you greg
first of all if i may we heard from the
president
last night a very emotional president
very determined and resolute though
yeah they talk at times like this in the
us of the need for a consoler in chief
offering solace to the country and and
joe biden is very good at that he's a
very empathetic man
and certainly delivered that uh he also
vowed there would be justice for those
who were behind
uh this uh this attack a very direct
threat to those who he says they have a
pretty good idea who it was and that
they will be targeting them but um he
says he took responsibility as the
president for what happened but he is
under huge pressure for a number of
reasons you have uh senior republicans
um in congress saying he should resign
he should be impeached he should be
removed
from office as a result of creating the
conditions they say that allow this
attack to happen with his handling of
this uh withdrawal that's the political
side and the white house has dismissed
it as politics but you also have the
american people who might well have been
watching what's been going on in
afghanistan over the last couple of
weeks but now see this as being very
personal they'll see 13 american service
personnel come home in coffins it has
brought it home to them and i think they
are looking more closely at how joe
biden has handled this and raising some
questions and criticism uh as well as
those republican politicians practically
uh he says the mission will continue as
it was continuing before it will end on
the 31st they believe there are some
pockets of americans they can still get
out before the troops leave i think the
feeling is if they changed their plan as
a result of of this attack that would
have been handing a victory to the
terrorists they want to plow on with
what they're doing he talked somewhat
intriguingly about the fact they believe
they can get americans now out after
the troops have gone on the on the 31st
relying it would seem on that
relationship they have with the taliban
to do that but they believe they will be
able to continue to do that and i think
joe biden under all this pressure is is
banking on one thing that the american
people for a number of years now the
polls have shown have wanted this war
over many felt they should have gone joe
biden felt they should have gone after
osama bin laden had been killed
and i think he believes in the long term
people will see that this plan is the
right plan that he's made the right
decision here but there's been an awful
cost in the last 24 hours and that is
hard for for americans to digest right
now
sally with us in doha sally we're
hearing from germany overnight no more
rescue flights as far as they're
concerned we have seen an airplane
herrera plane forgive me just taking off
from kabul airport but it's one of the
final few isn't it
i think that is the case case certainly
we were hearing as early as yesterday
that the number of evacuation flights
now really are numbered i wouldn't be
surprised if the last evacuation flights
indeed leave today of course doha here
in qatar is one of the main hubs for
american evacuation flights coming in
they've brought
more than 40 000 evacuees between the us
and the qataris in the last 13 days
since the taliban took control
of afghanistan but certainly the ability
to now extract people who aren't already
within the airport perimeter looks
very unlikely indeed of course uh
president biden and prime minister boris
johnson both very much trying to save
face yesterday saying that the mission
continues in terms of evacuations but
they're now very limited in terms of
what they can do from what i understand
there are no longer any soldiers outside
of the airport perimeter vetting people
with paperwork
in the crowds that will be over now
anyone turning up to the airport hoping
to get on a flight with their belongings
and their families i think will have a
very very difficult
time indeed that said there are around
10 000 people or at least there were at
the start of play today still within the
airport perimeter they will be evacuated
uh but there were reports i should say
of uh other explosions in kabul last
night now local reports suggest that
that were that was ammunition and depots
being blown up in anticipation of a
military withdrawal so i think very much
after that crowd that are within the
perimeter at the airport have been
evacuated that could be it and after
that we could see
the military presence there packed down
and fly out but what awful circumstances
they leave in
thank you the defense secretary ben
wallace is with us as we have these live
pictures from kabul airport hello to
minister thank you for joining us we do
have planes leaving about now don't we
yes we have about a thousand people uh
that we have taken
from the barons hotel for further
processing
uh afghan both under the arap scheme and
the leave outside the rules and british
nationals and they will be leaving
during the day how much longer can we do
this for
well we at 4 30 this morning the uk time
closed the barons hotel
shut the processing center and the gates
were closed abby gate and we will
process those people that we have
brought with us the thousand people
approximately inside the airfield now
and we will seek a way to
continue to find a few people in the
crowds where we can but overall the main
processing has now closed
and we have a matter of hours
i was speaking to a translator in the
last at the end of the last hour i'm
saying he's stuck with his wife and his
family and he can't get out and if he
stays there he'll die can we help him
well we can help him um we can't help
him as you know optimally as we like
right now obviously we've had to close
the hotel where we did the processing
uh the majority we've got out
approximately 13 000 people from the
arab interpreter scheme and the people
that help the ministry of defense and
the wider government network but as i've
said repeatedly for really the last two
weeks the sad fact is not every single
one
will get out we will make sure that we
have our visa processing centers or
indeed our enhanced capabilities in
around the region and those neighboring
countries and and people who can should
make their way to that third country and
we will
it depends where they are um it also
depends i think in the roles they're in
and we will give them advice about how
they can make their way somewhere but
also how they can look after themselves
at the moment but at the same time as
the g7 said
we're going to work quite hard with the
international community to put pressure
on the taliban
to honor
you know
the international obligations of
afghanistan to make sure that we give
those people as much as possible a safe
passage
and we do our very best by them
it does look like it's one of our planes
you were telling me if they've got a
white stripe on the back then that's
that's an american plane that doesn't
look as though it does when you see that
go up into the air like that it means
another several hundred people coming
back to the uk that must give you some
satisfaction look i i think we've had
almost one of the biggest airlifts of a
generation extraordinary
amount of effort by the raf and our
forces at risk and you know when we went
two weeks ago under what pitting on the
14th of august we went specifically for
this purpose we weren't we weren't there
to do other tasks we were there to
secure the airport and to get as many
people out as possible and you know it's
heading towards nearly 16 000
overall since april and you know nearly
14 000 since 14th of august that's
nearly a thousand people a day uh both
british nationals and afghan refugees to
some extent or certainly afghans who
helped us throughout the process
it it does but it doesn't temper the
overall feeling about what we're doing
leaving afghanistan after 20 years and
nor does it sort of temper the fact
there are still people that are going to
be in afghanistan that we couldn't get
out
given that you've closed the processing
center now not least because there was
an explosion um outside the hotel which
is where one of the processing centers
was um
how many more planes before that's it i
don't i don't know the slots but roughly
they were running at eight nine a day uk
planes you saw those big planes there
taking off the c-17s we could if we have
to vary the number of people allowed in
it we could break all the regulations i
authorized early on
uh a loosening of the regulation so we
could pack people in if we had to that
was you know the risk i thought was the
right to take and so we can do that we
have to now start removing the thousand
british forces they have to get out as
well the the amazing uh work that
they've done from 16 air assault brigade
their parachute regiment
and and indeed the other regiments
supporting them the yorks and the rifles
have done an extraordinary job and so
they have to get out as well out by the
31st or before within before uh i can't
i'm not going to give you for
operational reasons the actual date but
the us have been very clear they're
going to leave on the 31st of august the
the one thing i was moving out before
then yeah we have to they will be the
last people out and i you know my
thoughts today are with the families of
the 13
us soldiers killed uh yesterday and
indeed the you know approximate 80 to 90
afghans killed as well you know those
are we shouldn't forget with all the the
the turmoil that we see in the united
states at the moment the u.s put the
overwhelming force into that airport to
help us secure it over five to you know
about five to six thousand troops and it
has u.s troops who died yesterday
protecting that operation and i think
you know we have to be thankful for that
and grateful that they have enabled us
to do much of what you're seeing on the
telly and should we grieve for the
taliban fighters that died as well
i i agree for all loss of life that is
unnecessary i think it is pretty awful
uh what has happened to afghanistan in
50 60 years both with the soviet
invasion its poverty the the death we've
seen on the streets that the huge loss
of life of the afghan army we shouldn't
forget the brave afghan army that stood
in front of the taliban lost nearly 70
000 people fighting them
and i think we shouldn't forget that and
i look i you know the taliban
are have been our adversary have been
our enemy over those last 20 years they
have killed you know over 400 british
soldiers
in actions
so i'm not going to sit and say that you
know i
am you know pleased by what i see today
and yesterday with the taliban what i
would say
is that you know the loss of life the
attack by people like isis i mean what
what purpose was that going to serve to
blow up innocent people or all people
standing trying to leave the country
under humanitarian flights that is a
truly evil specter that we face in the
name of isis it's why isis is something
we take on all over the world where it
poses an imminent threat to the united
kingdom
are you uh what's intelligence saying
about any other threats in the next
couple of days or so well the threat is
obviously going to grow the closer we
get to leaving uh i think in a generic
form the narrative is always going to be
as we
leave
certain groups such as isis will want to
stake a claim that they have driven out
the u.s or the uk
and i think what i should make clear to
your viewers is that we closed the
barons hotel almost exactly on schedule
the explosion was horrendous
but it didn't hasten our departure we
were going last night
and that was always going to be once the
u.s had decided the 31st of august was
the final date okay but as far as live
threats are concerned is there any
intelligence to say that there's we
always have a we have a range of
intelligence there's quite a lot of
threat out there that's why we think
there's a highly likely and an even
greater risk of attack uh to our forces
and to afghans it's why yesterday the
foreign office beginning of the day
issued the stay away from the airport as
soon as that became real
there was a very clear warning now
that's easier said than done if you were
one of the thousands around the gate
and in fact the night before the british
army and others had pushed away from the
barons hotel a standoff uh area so up to
about 300 meters away from the barons
hotel and that is in fact where the
bomber uh detonated we think uh himself
at that um standoff so you know in in
recognition of the amazing work armed
forces did if they hadn't pushed that
perimeter further out i think we could
have been in worse place but of course
the americans we shouldn't forget the
loss of life from them they'll be
sending back 13
men and maybe women who died in action
and i think that is a real something
very sad for us all
what is the latest on casualty figures
do we have them so sadly an american
died overnight my understanding is he is
currently at 13
killed in action united states service
personnel uh considerable number of
injured uh that is obviously to be uh
firmed up as a number uh and about 60 to
80 afghans also tragically lost their
lives and they will have included
obviously families waiting in the canal
or by the canal for processing and the
uk military we were very lucky we've had
no
deaths as yet uh from the both this
operation and indeed uh yesterday
but of course uh that is uh you know
good professionalism but it's not all in
the hands of our soldiers it depends
what the bombers went it could have been
us it could have been us
are the taliban our foes or our allies
well i think at the moment what i'd say
is a taliban are running the country and
that is the simple fact we find
ourselves in that country and we have to
extract once that is over we have to
make a decision about our relationship
with the taliban and we want afghanistan
to hold to its international obligations
that it's signed up to under the former
government
we want to make sure that the afghan
government or regime that it becomes
doesn't host al qaeda
uh does something about isis
and lives to its actions that it
proves with its actions that its new
words mean something
i i think the jury is out on that i
think for now
they have uh you know our local level
our forces have engaged with them and
they have given us space to get people
out but as you've seen in the last 48
hours they've started to tighten that
screw turn back afghans and they've let
through british passport holders but
they've been turning back afghans
a couple of points before i let you go i
know you're very busy this morning um
the u.s has said that it's sharing
intelligence with the taliban including
biometrics um
to try and find out what's
getting people in and also uh concerned
about further attacks
um
that's quite a dangerous thing to do
isn't it
well i mean i can't speak for another
country what we do that's what i'm
saying is that what we would do in our
country the rules of how and who we
share intelligence with are guided by
regards for human rights we we are very
cautious about how we share intelligence
with the nation who doesn't have the
same human rights standards with us
obviously we have to find sometimes a
pragmatic way through if it means
we deal with an imminent threat to
ourselves but overall
we have lots of rules that govern that
we can't just hand out intelligence to
people as we feel it but um look
we're in the business of leaving
afghanistan today and over the next few
days
and uh i don't think you know if if
there's an imminent threat to life so
let's say we know someone is coming with
a bomb directly towards us or towards
other afghanis and we knew that
yesterday we well i can't speculate on
on exactly the detail we know we knew
there was an imminent threat um and
that's what we publicly talked about i
can't say to what extent we knew
and also whose intelligence it was it
may you know
the people who are in the intelligence
are the ones who get the right to decide
how they share it final thought
how will history view our involvement in
afghanistan
i think history's going to review
actually
this century's involvement in the early
part of this century is asking the west
the question which is
the west seems to think it fixes
problems rather than manages problems
you know the west seems to think it
flies in does a few things and
everything's going to be all right and
you don't fix problems like afghanistan
a thousand years of of tribal fighting
war
you manage them and if you wish to
engage in nation building or supporting
a nation you're probably best off doing
it as a international body now we did it
as nato but but
you know i think you're best off doing
that and you need to be prepared there
for the long run you know we were in
germany uh tom two gonna hurt my foreign
office my colleague who chairs the
foreign office committee you know he
talked about how long we were in the
cold war um you know they're long things
they're long events and uh you should be
prepared to do that and i think that's
the lesson and if not
uh then find another way and that's our
relationship with the united states been
damaged as a result of what's happened
no i mean
are you sure yeah look our relationship
with the united states is is like a
family and you know you know
we have siblings we are friends uh we
have
at all levels of the relationship we
have those type of cultural ties and
friendships and that's the real in my
experience special relationship you know
presidents come and go prime ministers
come and go in office but our deepest
relationship is both economic and
cultural and you know that if i go
tomorrow to any american headquarters
whether it is in hawaii where i visited
in the earlier part of the summer you'll
find one or two brits right in the heart
of their headquarters working alongside
the united states
you and i won't know their names
they won't be great admirals or generals
of the highest order
but they're there alongside each other
and that's the special relationship
it's great to talk to you i know you've
got a busy morning so i must let you go
thank you very much indeed and thanks
for uh talking us through the planes uh
leaving at kabul airport thank you
these are the live pictures uh from the
airport um as we speak the defense
secretary telling us that some of the
flights that we're leaving while we've
been live on air where the british uh
aircraft aircraft i should say coming
back to the united kingdom absolutely
full
to the gills with those who are trying
to flee
kabul
two suicide bomb attacks yesterday
85 people dead at least
well after the deaths of those 13
american personnel at a quarter to eight
i'm joined by lieutenant colonel daniel
davis who served two tours of
afghanistan with the u.s army
the u.s military leaders say they're now
working with the taliban against the
islamic state affiliate isis k we'll
talk to baroness pauline neville jones
former chair of the joint intelligence
committee that's at five past
eight british troops continuing to
rescue operations at kabul airport as
we've seen will get the thoughts of
general lord richard dannet the former
chief of the general staff that's at 20
past eight
we heard from president biden last night
he said we will hunt you down and make
you pay uh he made those comments he was
very very angry sometimes emotional at
the white house news conference last
night the deaths of 13 american troops
in yesterday's attack it's one of the
deadliest single incidents in the
history of the recent afghan conflict
from washington mark stone reports
after a day out of sight absorbing the
unfolding events the president emerged
to address the nation a tough day
with details of what had happened an
attack by a group known as isis k
took the lives of american service
members
standing guard at the airport and
wounded several others seriously as
president it was his decision which has
now resulted in such chaos and death but
he spoke as a father and a husband who
has experienced loss two children and a
wife we have some sense like many of you
do
what the families of these brave heroes
are feeling today
you get this feeling like you're being
sucked into a black hole in the middle
of your chest
there's no way out
my heart aches for you
and there was a warning for the
terrorists who carried out this attack
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay but the evacuation he
vowed would continue earlier at the
pentagon the generals were frank about
the ongoing threat a car bomb a suicide
attack or even a rocket at an aircraft
full of evacuees or troops and a
revelation that the cooperation with the
taliban now goes as far as sharing
intelligence
we share versions of this information
with the taliban so that they can
actually do some searching out there for
us and we believe that some attacks have
been thwarted by them
from behind this white house door in the
west wing president biden now has new
calculations new challenges and a
responsibility that he accepts is his
and so there was empathy there was
emotion but steadfastness from the
president too as commander-in-chief he
has now pledged to such conflicting
missions to continue with the evacuation
to get the troops out but also to hunt
down the terrorists that central
justification of his for pulling out
that afghanistan is no longer a home for
terrorists
well that has now been proved so
tragically wrong
his pledge was to bring troops out of
harm's way but a mission he ordered and
defended has now taken the lives of so
many more american and afghan mark stone
sky news in washington
and you can hear that full white house
news conference again throughout the day
here on sky news from half past 10 this
morning
meantime the prime minister said
yesterday despite the bomb attack rescue
flights to britain would continue for as
long as possible hearing from ben
wallace though uh the defense secretary
within the last few moments it looks as
though it's just a matter of hours now
the processing centre has closed down at
the barrens hotel about a thousand
people are in the system one or two
others who are trying to get to the
airport could also be swept up but apart
from that
it is over the last few flights coming
out very shortly rf bryce norton shaman
freeman powell is there for us so some
more flights coming in we've seen them
leaving kabul heading toward towards
where you are but not many more to come
shimon
yeah that's right as you said despite
the devastating scenes coming out of
afghanistan over the past 24 hours the
prime minister has confirmed that the uk
evacuation effort will still be going
ahead and it is likely that we will see
more planes arriving here at bryce
norton over coming hours as well as
other parts of the uk now last night the
ministry of defense confirmed that
they've already evacuated more than 13
000 people from afghanistan and that the
prime minister will continue to get as
many people as possible evacuated from
afghanistan over the coming hours and he
claims actually that the vast majority
of those who are entitled to come to the
uk have already been evacuated but some
mps have been disputing this they say
they've had constituents writing to them
to say that family members who are
entitled to come to the uk haven't been
able to do so and of course that suicide
bombing last night will only make that
even more difficult for people trying to
get to the airport the prime minister
says that inevitably some people will be
left behind but he will continue to work
right until the last moment the final
minutes to get as many people out as
possible and he said that even after
august the 31st he will do everything
within his power to make sure that the
taliban will still allow people to leave
the country so it is clear that even
though the deadline is looming and we
are in the final stages that this is far
from over
so the rescue mission is almost over the
ministry of defense has announced that
it is scaling back its rescue operation
in kabul a short time ago the defence
secretary ben wallace told me that
british flights would be ending in his
words shortly
we at 4 30 this morning the uk time
closed the barons hotel
shut the processing center and the gates
were closed abby gate and
we will process those people that we
have brought with us the thousand people
approximately inside the airfield now
and uh we will seek a way to
continue to find a few people in the
crowds where we can but overall the main
processing has now closed
and we have a matter of hours
so a thousand people inside the
perimeter of the airport they will be on
flights back to the united kingdom one
or two that are in the crowd outside
potentially will also be able to return
after that the brits are pulling out of
afghanistan after 20 years
it's over taliban says the death toll
from yesterday's suicide bomb attack has
risen to at least 72 with 13 american
service personnel also killed
the defense secretary said he was
shocked by the attack
what i would say
is that you know the loss of life the
attack by people like isis i mean what
on what purpose was that going to serve
to blow up innocent people or all people
standing trying to leave the country
under humanitarian flights that is a
truly evil specter that we face in the
name of isis it's why isis is something
we take on all over the world where it
poses imminent threat to the united
kingdom
tamara's here and tomorrow you were
listening to uh the defense secretary as
we look at these pictures from kabul he
was basically saying it's almost over
yes this is this is the end game now and
the planes that do take off from kabul
airport you can see there will be
people who are already in the airport
british nationals and afghans who have
already been processed they will not be
any more people coming through that
processing center essentially for those
crowding outside the airport perimeter
the hope has been extinguished now of
them getting into the airport showing
their documents and getting on a plane
the defense secretary didn't rule out
the odd person being picked out of the
crowd but he said it was not worth
people coming to the airport
speculatively that is something they've
had a huge struggle with over the last
few days people coming speculatively
without the right documents potentially
holding up people who are eligible to
walk onto a plane but around a thousand
people now in the airport will go
everybody else will not go and we expect
that to be a matter of hours we saw
british transporter uh taking off we saw
people snaking onto the back of of that
transporter we're also hearing from ben
wallace that he's given the authority
for people to be basically rammed into
those airplanes sat on the floor with
ropes between them so they can get as
many people in as they possibly can but
after today it's done it it sounds like
that they will not confirm the official
end of the operation or exactly when the
final troops and kit will be leaving
kabul but it's it's in the final hours
now and it was interesting that the
defense actually confirmed that the
closure of the processing facilities at
the barrens hotel which is the the hotel
next to kabul airport um has closed on
schedule of course they didn't tell us
the schedule but that but that it was
planned that it would close now ahead of
the american pull-out on tuesday he said
that yesterday's attack has not hastened
our departure and that british troops
will bravely continue with the
evacuation despite of course the hugely
dangerous conditions that they're
working in
one also wonders what happens as far as
the hardware is concerned is it a
scorched earth policy do they try and
get it out of the country because we
know that an awful lot of the military
hardware as far as the us is concerned
has found itself now in the hands of the
taliban well the government have not
confirmed anything mod has not confirmed
anything but we know that there's
obviously got to be difficult decisions
made about whether you put helicopters
onto transport planes or whether you
prioritize people and you then destroy
some of that hardware in kabul and this
has been much discussed in in the us
because the us have a much larger number
of american nationals and american green
card holders who
are still in kabul and many of them may
still be in kabul after tuesday so
there's been a very sharp debate across
the atlantic about how much kit is
brought home but of course massive
criticism as well by republicans that
some of this kit that we used to give to
the afghan army is now in the hands of
people who were until the last a few
weeks ago our our sworn enemies
uh tuesday being the 31st of august of
course bear with us if you would please
tomorrow because i want to bring in uh
sir nicholas k he's uk ambassador to
afghanistan
somalia sudan drc
democratic republic of condo of course
you're looking at these pictures sir
nicholas with us we have seen a
transporter take off uh presumably with
several hundred people on board heading
towards the united kingdom but we're
hearing from the defense secretary
saying it's a matter of hours now and
then we are out after 20 years your
reaction to that first of all
yeah thank you i mean these are very
very sad and uh
dangerous days that we're going through
now and i think the final days of uh
this evacuation will be even
more tense and more dangerous you know
the risk of attacks is is not over
unfortunately um so
yeah
tense difficult what i hope
from the bottom of my heart though is
that this is not
the end um after tuesday 31st of august
afghanistan is not going to disappear
and nor are many of those afghans who
already have either the right to to
relocate to other countries or the
strong wish to do so
so we really do need to start to to
focus on how this
relocation of afghans can continue after
the 31st of august through
civilian means through reopening the
airport and through cooperation with the
taliban
and that's the immediate priority but
there's plenty of other priorities which
i hope will see us remaining engaged in
some way in afghanistan
eerily calm at the airport at the moment
uh the last thousand people to be
airlifted out by the brits are now
inside the perimeter it's a very very
dangerous situation the other side of
that perimeter fence isn't it
it is i mean what we've seen is that you
know
the the ability of the taliban to
provide security control the city is far
from far from perfect these are these
are not well trained uh forces it's a
huge city um
what you know yesterday's
horrible gruesome attack was for me just
rather too familiar
is kp islamic state horizon province
have been doing these kind of attacks
for the last few years horrendous
attacks on maternity hospital on schools
so
what the difference now is
is there is no capability on the ground
or much reduced capability to deal with
it um you know the us and uk and others
were working very very closely with
afghan security and intelligence forces
and foiling and deterring and
neutralizing many of these threats over
years now that capability has gone
so nicholas what fate are we leaving
those two that are left behind and can't
get on these planes
very mixed i mean i i'm not one that
believes that the taliban have changed i
believe they have
learnt what they should be saying and
how they should be presenting themselves
uh but i think we need to judge them by
their actions uh and it is also unclear
you know this is nearly two weeks after
they came into the city i get the sense
they're struggling actually to
be coherent and to get in place a
government they haven't yet got a
government with appointed people they
are finding the same challenges as
anyone in charge in kabul how do you
bring a very diverse disparate nation
together how does everybody every
stakeholder get the share that they
think they should get and that extends
also within the taliban ranks itself you
know there are our divisions there okay
so
so nicholas
this is um live pictures from kabul
airport this is obviously a charter
flight that is that is coming in uh we
know that it's really only the brits and
the americans that are running those
charter flights uh anymore um a few
lucky people um perhaps animals will be
on board that aircraft but also watching
these pictures will be not only um the
taliban but also
isis k this group that's accepted
responsibility claimed responsibility
for what happened yesterday
what is the relationship between the
taliban and isis k are they sworn
enemies
um they are i mean over the
years there has been a degree you could
say almost of not
not operational cooperation between them
but uh the
uh the network that supports terrorists
that's people who move
bombs and bomb making equipment to move
suicide bombers and things like that
it's almost a criminal network and
there is some overlap in
isis k using the same networks as the
taliban sometimes but to all intents and
purposes sworn enemies now and uh it is
one of those ironies that now you know
potentially for the us and the west the
taliban are
allies against is in in afghanistan
and if we are serious now about
continuing counter-terrorism work in
afghanistan to stop afghanistan being a
haven for international terrorists and
is our international terrorists um then
we may need to reinforce cooperation
with
with whatever government emerges and
that is part of the challenge there is
no government yet
fernado's nicholas the air corridor
looks so it's almost closed what about
the land borders you know the area well
how difficult would it be to get over a
land border
i mean the land borders are
traditionally
popular and choke points there's huge
crowds already at the southern land
border spin bold act south of kandahar
and the border across to pakistan as
well after jalalabad is is crowded and
open i mean those will be routes that
people will look to look to use and
i mean this is you know as we have many
have said but let's not take our eye off
also the huge humanitarian challenge in
the country i mean there is the risk of
starvation there is certainly food in
security this is a country that relies
on foreign assistance so you know people
are going to suffer you see those
mountains behind kabul airport you know
the first snows will come in about a
month
and you know from then onwards it gets
harsher and harsher so you know
afghanistan is facing you know multiple
challenges now both humanitarian
political and terrorist and
for my money that is a very good reason
why the uk and other nations should
still remain engaged and i hope we will
find a way to keep open at least some
office in in kabul it's difficult given
the security environment and nobody will
rush into it rationally safety of staff
is is really really important
but i believe we should remain engaged
to pursue humanitarian interests to
pursue terrorism interests in the region
okay cynical thank you for joining us on
the programme a very challenging time
for all involved thank you sir nicholas
we appreciate it
that charter jet has now landed as you
can see at kabul airport around about
45 minutes after a british transport
flight
took
refugees both brits and indeed afghans
eligible to come to the united kingdom
out of kabul it is one of the final
flights that left we heard from the
defense secretary speaking to us on this
program that a thousand people have been
processed they're now within the
perimeter of the airport the processing
center which was about half a kilometer
or so away that has now been closed down
in the early hours of this morning as
far as the brits are concerned anybody
that is coming to the united kingdom bar
one or two people who might be outside
the perimeter of the airport and can be
easily identified apart from that
the operation by the british government
is almost over within a matter of hours
it will be done says the defense
secretary
[Music]
hello again yesterday's suicide bombing
um i was one of the single deadliest
attacks involving american troops since
operations began in afghanistan in 2001
as we look at live pictures from kabul
airport we heard from our defense
secretary here in the uk that we are now
nearing the end game as far as british
involvement in afghanistan is concerned
after 20 years joined by retired u.s
army lieutenant colonel daniel davis
who's served twice
in afghanistan
good morning to you so i'm not sure if
you can see these live pictures as we're
speaking to you um
it is only a matter of time now
before it's all over for the military
personnel both uh us
and uk
you have served in afghanistan
previously what do you think when you
look at these pictures
uh it's it's it's really surreal i still
haven't been able to really come to
grips with with what all this means uh
you know i spent so much time there in
both the in the two combat deployments
in 2005 and six uh 2010 and 11 then went
back also uh as a civilian uh and and
it's just it's just hard to believe
that all of these places that were just
such a routine regular part of this like
at bagram air base where my headquarters
was it's it was literally like a small
city a small american city with shopping
centers and uh you know traffic in the
middle of town uh it was just uh
just really an unbelievable thing that
is now literally gone they're completely
in taliban control and very soon as you
say all of it will be gone yeah looking
at this transporter another transporter
that's about to take off was speaking to
our defense secretary he said uh the us
and the uk both use the same the only
difference is there's a white stripe on
the tail fin i can't really that looks
as though it probably does have one but
you would know better than me so um
another plane just arriving as well um
it belies what's happening outside uh
because it absolute pandemonium i
believe outside the perimeter uh of the
airport as people scramble to get onto
these last few flights out one wonders
uh what fate uh belies those that
don't manage to get on these airplanes
well from what we're saying it might not
be as dire as is what some have
predicted uh the taliban have been very
outspoken about the fact that they're
gonna allow uh civilian flights to
continue going and operating the minute
that we finish on the 31st september
first they'll be allowed to do that uh
and it's gonna they may take some time
to get that ramp back up but those
things are going to continue to be able
to happen under civilian at least not
american military western military
powers and we should do everything that
we can to facilitate that president
biden said earlier today in his speech
that even after we leave we are still
going to do everything we can to take
care of the people that that
are not able to get on these final
flights uh and you know it's going to be
much more challenging but if we going to
have any chance at all to influence the
taliban both for that and for also some
of the governance issues that come later
to you know so that they don't abuse
their people so they don't take all the
rights away that so many people have
earned over the last 20 years we're
going to have to work with them whether
we like it or not frankly um they have
said quite a lot of things already
including um they've changed they're
going to treat women differently they
won't um be going door to door to seek
retribution against those that work with
the allied forces
quite a lot of those promises have not
stood the test of time it being less
than two weeks since they said that are
you saying that we should take them at
their word when they say that they are
going to open uh the um the commercial
side of the airport
right i mean there's no work there's
nothing to take there's no word to take
we we just have to do what we can to
influence them the fact is
we're we lost this war we are out within
just a few days so it doesn't matter
whether we whether we trust them or not
it only matters what they're going to do
and that's why i say it's so important
that we do whatever we can to have as
much influence positive influences as we
can for the people of afghanistan for
those people who still need to get out
and no we can't trust anything they say
it is 100 gonna be uh watching their
deeds that's the only thing that's going
to matter okay we appreciate you staying
up late for us in washington early hours
of this morning in washington thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning my pleasure thank you thank you
almost five to three in the morning in
washington uh it is um
24 minutes past 11 00 in the morning in
kabul looking at these images another
plane that is at taxiing ready for
takeoff we've seen another transporter
aircraft taking off with several hundred
people
on board within the last hour we've seen
a a couple of other aircraft uh arriving
at the airport but we did hear from our
defense secretary if you're just tuning
our way this morning he did tell us that
it is a matter of hours now before the
british operation in kabul is over
they've closed the processing center
which was just outside the airport
perimeter about a thousand people have
now been moved inside the perimeter of
kabul airport they will be airlifted to
the united kingdom within the next few
hours then after that within a matter of
hours according to the defense secretary
the mission after 20 years
is over